-Our next guest
is a very funny comedian
you know from films
such as "Happiest Season,"
"Always Be My Maybe,"
and her Netflix special,
"Michelle Buteau:
Welcome to Buteaupia."
She returns as host of the
social-media competition serie
"The Circle," which streams ne
episodes Wednesdays on Netflix
Please welcome to the show
Michelle Buteau, in studio
♪♪♪♪
Whoo!
-Oh, oh, oh!
Hi, everybody!
-Welcome!
People!
It's human being!
[ Laughs ]
-I'm here!
-We're so,
so happy to have you here.
-I am so happy to be had.
Are you kidding?
-And you -- you used to work
in local news for WNBC
here in the building?
-Yes, here in 30 Rock.
I worked on
the sixth or seventh floor
Who knows?
It was a long time ago.
I age well.
-[ Chuckles ]
-And I worked
the overnight shoot.
And it was so crazy
because I would come in, like,
a little tipsy every day.
No big deal.
I was creative.
That's what everyone thought
-Right.
-And I would just edit
house fires and fall aslee
in my chair and just, like
eat bagels and craved breakfas
for four years.
I am so excited to be here
I'm always talking
to my 2-year-old twins,
and you're an adult!
-[ Laughs ]
2-year-old twins, my goodness.
So you started a pandemic
basically with one --
two 1-year-olds
at the same time.
-Yeah.
And my husband.
So it felt like three children
-[ Laughs ]
-I'm just saying,
pick up after yourself.
-[ Laughs ]
-You know what?
This is so --
I love that no one's here to
like, laugh, because it feel
like I've just started comed
all over again.
[ Laughter ]
There it is!
-It's giving you flashbacks?
Flashbacks to the early days
-A little bit, a little bit.
Like, where's my drink ticket,
you know?
-[ Laughs ]
When you say --
What time did your shift start
at WNBC for the overnight?
-Sometimes midnight,
sometimes 1:30 a.m.
-Oof!
-Yeah. And I would
sneak comedians in here.
This was before security
was really tight.
I'm just spilling all the tea.
-Yeah.
-What is it, teatime?
Oh, my God.
Plus-sized Meghan Markle,
take it down!
-[ Laughs ]
-And I used to give them
the 10-cent tour and take them
to the "SNL" studios
just to get, like, a quick pic
-So you were doing that jo
when you were still
getting started as a comedian?
-Yes.
I actually started stand-u
a few days after 9/11,
because I worked so many hours
just editing
the worst possible footage
and I thought, "This is a good
time to start stand-up."
-Yeah.
-I mean, not really,
when you think about it.
I mean, if you thought
the news was gnarly,
and then that happened,
you'd be, like,
"This is a good time
to get out,"
and I think it proved
that you were right.
-Well, thank you very much
Are you my therapist?
I'm gonna leave you
four out of four Zocdoc.
You are doing it.
-[ Laughs ]
-You know, I didn't
used to feel like a therapist,
but ever since people
had to move from the chair
to the couch...
[ Laughter ]
-I know!
-So you -- I deeply felt
for comedians
who had schedules --
sorry,
had scheduled their specials
and then, because of this...
-Yeah.
-...lost that chance,
because obviously, I think
there's, mentally, your timing
for that moment, right?
You want the material
to be just right.
You were scheduled, like,
two weeks after
everything shut down,
and you moved it up.
-Yeah.
-Not knowing, right?
-No, not at all.
-So you got it in
just under the wire?
-Yes. And I picked March 1st
that date, 2020,
'cause it's
my grandmother's birthday,
and she's no longer with us,
but I thought,
"What a great fun night
to still celebrate Mavis
and, you know,
get the special in."
And Netflix
and the production company
really thought we should do it
at the end of March.
And I'm just like, "Look, y'all,
I've been doing comedy
for 18 years.
I can do the special tomorro
on a subway platform.
Let's just get it done."
You know what I mean?
So I'm so glad I did
because then I got to, like,
share it with
the rest of the world.
But I think also just
dropping content
during probably
one of the worst years...
-Yeah.
-...of our life,
it was conflicting because
there is so much going on,
I didn't want to be, like,
"Hey, everyone.
I know you're waiting
on your stimulus check,
but, mm,
can you like my special?"
It's so crazy.
But I also realized that,
you know,
people really needed some joy.
A lot of people keep telling m
they joy-watched it,
which makes me feel
like a size 16.
I'm ready to go
bathing-suit shopping
every time somebody says that.
-You obviously got to edit i
in a time when everybody
was locked down.
So you actually
had a thing to do.
Did you enjoy going through it
and watching this?
-No, I hate watching myself!
It's like being in one of thos
expensive hotels
where there's a mirror
right in front of the toilet
-[ Laughs ]
You know what it feels like.
You don't got to watch it.
Too much, too soon.
Look at my legs, yes, come on.
Skinny ankles.
I'm gonna get it.
-Your boots look great,
everything.
-I look like
a substitute teacher
that could pass a drug test.
[ Laughter ]
-You did -- the pandemic
did require you to change --
even though I should say
"Welcome to Buteaupia"
is a wonderful title,
it was not your first choice
-It was not.
We were originally going to call
it "A Good Ass Year,"
'cause I was having
such a good year.
[ Laughter ]
And then everybody,
including myself, we were having
a not-so-good year.
So we're, like,
"We can't call it
'A Good Ass Year.'
That's too much."
That's like calling my special
"I Got All
My Stimulus Checks on Time."
It's like,
"Stop bragging, bitch."
And so --
Can I say "bitch"?
-Yeah.
-Oh, well, bitch!
[ Laughter ]
-How many people?
Like seven?
-Well, you can't say it twice.
-I'm sorry!
[ Laughter ]
Don't come at me.
But, yeah, we ended up going
with "Welcome to Buteaupia
because that was always sort of,
you know, a plan B
in the back of my mind,
but I was also, like,
people always mess up my name,
so I thought this would, like,
be a really fun way
to introduce people
to not only my world
but my last name.
-Yeah.
-And we talked
a little bit backstage.
It was so --
You won a Critic's Choice awar
for this special.
You share the award
with Jerry Seinfeld.
-Who's that?
Just kidding!
-It's nice! It's nice for both
of you guys to get a break
[ Laughter ]
-It was so crazy because whe
home girl was, like,
"It's a tie.
That means two people won.
I'm, like,
"I know what that means girl."
And then she said Seinfeld
I was like,
"Oh, I got to lose twice? Okay."
Just trying to smile
the whole time.
But it's so wild.
I mean, I'm so grateful
and thankful because, you know
this is why I always tell people
whatever you want to do,
don't give up.
Just keep doing
whatever you got to do
because it won't happen
when you expect it to,
but it'll be so much sweeter
And, you know, the fact that
I finally got to not only
be nominated but win,
but also be in my pajamas
and a dress at home is crazy
But, you know,
the biggest thing is, you know
my kids will look back on that
and be proud of me.
You know what I mean?
-Yeah.
-They'll be, like,
"Mom won this."
The first female to win,
which is bananas.
-I did not even realize that
That's crazy.
I also want to ask about this.
I had spent a few years
living in Holland.
You're married
to a Dutch gentleman.
-I am.
Gijs is his name.
-[ Laughs ]
Wait. "Heis"?
Wait. So, G-E-I-S?
-G-I-J-S.
-Yes.
-Oh, my God. So Buteau's hard.
What do people call him?
-Boo. They call him Bob,
they call him Boo, James.
I mean, you sprecha
the Nederlands, no?
-Een beetje.
-Okay.
-Een klein beetje.
-Okay. I'mma hype it.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Speaking Dutch ]
-Oh, I don't know
what that means!
I need subtitles!
Okay, Rosetta Stone.
No, it's really interestin
being married to someone
that speaks a language tha
not a lot of people understand
-Right.
-Because they always think
it's German
or something South African
like Afrikaans or whatever
So, yeah, man,
it's a whole learning lesson
-And is he speaking it
to the twins?
-He is.
-All right.
So they know like "cheese"
and "kaas,"
and they'll just say dog and doy
and goodbye and stuff.
And I love it.
You know, a lot of people are,
like, "Do you want to know
what they're saying?"
I'm, like, "No,
I want to take a break.
-[ Laughs ] Right.
-Let them talk to each other
You come at me if you need me.
You know where I'm at.
I'll be in the kitchen,
washing these spoons."
-You were saying --
You know, and again,
I think a lot of comedians, it's
been a really difficult year
Again, you caught a break in
that you got your special out.
But, you know, especially when
you're building a stand-up act
it's so important
to have an audience.
-Yeah.
-Whereas, when you're doin
a half-baked monologue,
it's totally the same.
-[ Laughs ]
-But you -- I want to ask this
because I did do comedy
for a long time
in front of Dutch audiences.
I find them to be
a very fair audience
but a very honest audience
-You sound like you're married
to a Dutch person.
No, they're horrible.
I'm just kidding!
Look, no, Dutch people,
it's really funny.
Dutch people are sort of
like your family, right?
So, you know, you can't make fun
of them, but, you know,
they can make fun of themselves,
but you can't make fun of them
They get very offended.
-Gotcha.
-But, um, you know,
funny is funny.
So I feel like
if the world is laughing,
then they'll laugh along.
So now they like it.
But before, when I was working
my material out there,
they didn't like it.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-But I --
They're a very honest people
So, is that helpful?
When you -- Does your husban
tell you when --
I mean, I'm sure he's a fa
of yours, but is he ever like,
"This part is not funny"?
-Um, you know, he knows now.
I told him, it's not what yo
say, it's how you say it.
So it's not like,
"It's not funny."
It's just like, "You could use
more work on that."
-Right.
-Do you know what I mean?
-That's good.
-Yeah, but they're very blunt...
-Gotcha.
-...even when you don't
want to know.
-My wife is not Dutch,
but she got a Dutch passport
so she could criticize me.
[ Laughter ]
-I love that.
Do you know, 10 years ago, I did
a pilot with your brother?
-I do.
-In L.A. for the E! Network,
and I'm still waiting to hea
if it gets picked up.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, I hope it does!
-Congratulations on the second
season of "The Circle."
Is that a fun show to do?
-Oh, it's so much fun.
I mean, season one, it was like,
"What a wild idea.
We're all gonna be
in quarantine.
What's that like?!"
And now season two, we're like
"Yeah, yeah, we got it.
We got it.
Let me just win this money."
But it's very fun.
-Well, that's cool.
Congratulations on that
and the special.
And very excited, as I am
with all comedians I'm fans of
to see you back
in front of people again.
It will be great for all of us
Season two of "The Circle"
is streaming now on Netflix.
-Yes!